tengo una expresión racional aquí y mi
objetivo es simplificar la y mientras
hago digamos esta simplificación quiero
asegurarme de que la expresión que
obtengamos sea algebraica mente
equivalente así que habrá ciertos
valores de x para los que esta expresión
simplificada que encontremos no deberá
estar definida verdad así que por lo que
digamos tendremos que restringir nuestra
expresión simplificada y no considerar
dichos valores así que como siempre te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta
muy bien ahora vamos a resolverlo todos
juntos primero tenemos que preguntarnos
para qué valores de x esta expresión no
está definida y realmente lo único que
tenemos que fijarnos es en el
denominador verdad tenemos que pensar
cuando es que el denominador se anula
verdad porque no podemos dividir entre 0
entonces aquí es muy fácil de ver el
único valor de x para el cual el
denominador se anula es x igual a cero
así que x no puede ser cero verdad muy
bien ahora lo que podemos observar es
que tanto el numerador como el
denominador tenemos que todos estos
coeficientes son divisibles entre 7
verdad y todos tienen al menos una equis
entonces digamos tanto el numerador como
denominador son divisibles entre 7x así
que vamos a factorizar 7x en el
numerador y en el denominador verdad
aquí tenemos
x 7 x en el numerador tendrá que
multiplicar aquí a 2 x verdad 7 x x 2x
son 14 x cuadrada más 1 verdad más 17 x
más 1 perdón 7 x x 1 nos da 7 x ahora en
el denominador será 7 x x 2 para que nos
dé 14 x muy bien y recuerden tenemos que
cargar con nuestra restricción x no
puede ser 0 para que mantengamos estas
expresiones algebraica mente
equivalentes muy bien ahora podemos
observar que este 7x entre 7 x pues se
hace se hace una verdad es decir podemos
cancelarlo de esta expresión y entonces
obtenemos que 2x + 1 entre 2 es la
expresión digamos equivalente a estas
anteriores verdad pero por supuesto
tenemos que poner que x sea distinto de
0 y estos aquí sí es importante verdad
porque esta expresión que tenemos aquí
2x
1 / 2 siempre está definida verdad
siempre está definida incluso en 0 sin
embargo no puede ser 0 pues queríamos
que fuera algebraica mente equivalente a
esta expresión de antes verdad entonces
esto puede parecer un detalle sutil por
es bastante importante por ejemplo si
esta de aquí fuera una función verdad
entonces esta función no estaría
definida en x igual a 0 y entonces para
que esta de aquí y esta de aquí abajo
fueran exactamente la misma función
deben tener el mismo dominio así que sí
sino que si no ponemos esta restricción
entonces si serían equivalentes salvo en
x igual a 0 pero queremos que sean
algebraica mente equivalente es verdad
entonces hay que poner esta restricción
y todavía podríamos simplificar esta
esta expresión de aquí por ejemplo
podemos dividir entre 2 estos dos suman
2 y entonces obtendríamos
más vamos a ponerlo así 2x entre 2 sería
x + 1 entre 2 que es un medio verdad
otra vez con la restricción de que x no
puede ser 0 muy bien hagamos otro
ejercicio
ok entonces tenemos este ejemplo este
ejemplo parece más complicado verdad
pero vamos a tratar de hacer exactamente
lo mismo vamos a simplificar esta
expresión pero vamos a tratar de ser
consistentes con los puntos que tenemos
que restringir para que las expresiones
que vayamos obteniendo sean algebraica
mente equivalentes muy bien entonces
vamos primero a tratar de factorizar el
numerador y el denominador y ahí veremos
cuáles son los puntos que tenemos que ir
restringiendo verdad entonces aquí
podemos ver que todos estos coeficientes
son divisibles entre 10 y 7 verdad
entonces podríamos factorizar 17 y
también podemos ver que todos estos
términos tienen al menos una seta
cuadrada verdad entonces podríamos
factorizar 17 se está cuadrada verdad y
en el numerador por ejemplo tendríamos
que multiplicar por 17 st cuadrado por
zeta para que nos dé 17 z cúbica
una verdad para que 17 se está cuadrada
por 12 de 17 z cuadrada y todo esto hay
que dividirlo entre otra vez factor
izamos 17 se está cuadrada y
multiplicamos por quién bueno
multiplicamos por 2 z verdad 12 está por
17 se está cuadrada nos da 34 z cúbica y
aquí hay que poner menos 3 verdad 3 por
17 nos da 51 y tenemos está cuadrada y
este signo menos entonces aquí tenemos
ya factor izada esta expresión verdad y
aquí podemos rápidamente ver cómo es que
hay que restringir tenemos que pensar
cuando es que el denominador se anula y
esto es cuando se está es igual a 0
gracias a éste se está cuadrada verdad
se está igual a 0 es decir se está no
puede ser 0 en esta expresión y ahora
pensemos cuando es que este otro factor
se anula es decir cuando es que 2 c
- 3 nos da 0 si sumamos 3 de ambos lados
tenemos 12 está igual a 3 y si dividimos
entre 2 de ambos lados tendremos 7 igual
a 3 medios entonces tampoco puede ser
que z tome el valor de tres medios muy
bien estas son las restricciones que
debemos considerar muy bien entonces si
continuamos podemos ver que estos dos
factores se pueden cancelar y obtenemos
la expresión zeta más uno dividido entre
dos z menos tres y otra vez esto debe
tener las mismas restricciones verdad z
tiene que ser distinto de cero y
podríamos poner que z es distinto de
tres medios sin embargo esta restricción
ya está implícita aquí en esta expresión
ya que el denominador es 2 z menos 3 y
justo en tres medios es cuando se anula
entonces bien podríamos no ponerla
quizás voy a tratar de ser redundante
vamos a poner que z sea distinto de tres
medios aunque simplemente de la
expresión que ya tiene
aquí queda claro que no puede ser tres
medios verdad entonces la primera
restricción es importante porque ésta no
es obvia a partir de esta expresión sin
embargo es importante ponerla para que
tengamos expresiones algebraica mente
equivalentes